ici comme partout en france les
recommandations d'hygiène ont été
appliquées marquage au sol pour
respecter une distance d'un mètre entre
les personnes port de masques et de
gants pour les assesseurs et surtout
mise à disposition de gel
hydroalcoolique des mesures nécessaires
pour lutter contre l'épidémie de
coronavirus mais pas encore ancré dans
les habitudes des électeurs et j'ai tout
respecter les mesures at elle pourrait
que j'y trouvais que j'ai mis ma carte
d'identité dans l'urne dans ce bureau de
vote de montigny le bretonneux on ne se
bouscule pas pour accéder aux isoloirs
néanmoins le maire sortant jean luc
ourgaud se montre optimiste à l'heure où
je vous parle
11' rosso modo on est à peu près au même
niveau de vote que 2014
il va falloir voir l'évolution dans la
journée je dois reconnaître que je ne
m'attendais pas à terminer un mandat va
dire sur les chapeaux de roue comme ça
c'était vraiment quelque chose qui
n'était pas prévu on termine
difficilement mais sereinement quand
même parce qu'on a pris le maximum de
précautions pour que les gens puissent
voter comme il faut c'est notre devoir
civique en vente au saint malo exprès
donc on est bien notée mais ce que je
comprends pas très bien c'est que on
permet aux gens de venir voter voilà et
entre partis y a plus d'école il ya plus
de magasins il faut qu'on nous explique
quand même la chose l'armée bron une
incompréhension partagée par beaucoup
d'habitants avec la question de savoir
si le deuxième tour sera maintenu pour
l'heure aucune annulation n'est prévue
et les dépouillements de ce premier tour
se dérouleront normalement ou presque